hey this is matt from nmr i'm here with
the one and only heather russell hello
heather how are you i'm good thank you
good good so you guys are out here from
toronto correct yes we drove across
october oh very very cool doing a little
touring right sorry doing a little
touring seeing the country yeah it was
amazing driving through all the states
yeah absolutely so you know you're known
for your singing and songwriting
especially on youtube you know most 12
year olds don't really know what they
want to do with the rest of their life
um but you seem to know i have a good
grasp you're already recording music or
recording on youtube you know when did
you decide that you wanted to start
being a singer-songwriter
well
throughout my life i have enjoyed music
my entire life so i had always known
that music was like my passions in my
blood my dad's musician
from when i can remember like three
years old my dad saying what sounds
right play what doesn't sound like don't
play on the piano
knowing that ears are most important so
i had always known that music was like
my savior yeah absolutely you know and
on your on your facebook page under
influences it says that um you know
freddie mercury's one of your big
influences and you know
queen front man where did you first hear
queen in here about uh freddie mercury
actually my my mom and i um research a
lot of the grades and so my mom came
across freddie mercury and so i started
watching his songs and the moment i
heard his song it like it hit me my
favorite song from him is bohemian
rhapsody
all the different chord changes and
and melodies and the passion and his
voice i i love him yeah yeah very cool
you know um you were born in
2000 so you've never really known a
world without the internet um you know
if youtube wasn't around do you think
he'd still be performing and going out
and making songs oh yeah for sure i mean
youtube is a big help but if it wasn't
there it doesn't mean i'm you know gonna
stop doing music always my parents are
still gonna help me pursue my dreams and
i'm still gonna be performing at local
places and just try to find ways to you
know
get it but youtube's made it a lot
easier to kind of get your name out
there and get a family yeah i think
youtube not only youtube but the
internet is really important because it
helps me you know engage with my fans
and get to know them better and they get
to know me better so i think it's really
important yeah absolutely and uh you
know you you just recently did um an
alicia keys song and you do a lot of
popular songs how do you kind of pick
which songs you're gonna cover on your
youtube channel well i don't i don't
usually do cover so when i do do cover i
say dude when i do do covers um they
have to be really like
i have to be really passionate about the
song like and i have to love the song so
when i heard girl on fire
when i decided to cover that song i had
fans asking me in comments like for me
to cover songs when i did cover that
song that was really important to me
because i i love alicia keys i think
she's amazing she's so real
and that song just like it touches me i
love the melodies and everything about
it she's pretty great yeah she's really
awesome are there any covers that you're
planning to do that you've always really
really wanted to do
well i have a um
i don't know if i i think i have a
couple more or a cover coming out soon
and so like i said when i do a cover
it's really important like i love this
song
i would cover mariah carey all i want
for christmas is you it's good song i
think he's coming out so very cool yeah
do you have a favorite song of all time
just in general yeah um it's by ceelo
green
uh crazy it's a good song my favorite
song
in the entire world i love i love his
voice i think he's amazing and the best
part about it is every time he performs
live he can sing it you know what i mean
like when he sings it he's dead on i
think this song is just it's amazing i
love everything about it yeah absolutely
and he's a judge on the voice yeah he is
would you ever want to do any of those
songs like the voice or x factor i'm not
the songs but competitions like the x
factor the voice um i would love to
perform on on the voice and and all
those shows because i i would love to
perform anywhere i think the smallest
place on earth earth performing there is
great so performing there would be you
know
awesome also i love the shows they're
great so yeah i think it'd be awesome
and so the judges on um the voice are
ceelo greene adam levine christina
aguilera and blake shelton yeah if you
had to pick one of those judges which
one do you think would be your coach
i think they're all great i think
they're all awesome but if i had to pick
um
i'd either pick i um i think i picked
cee-lo yeah ceelo or christina yeah i
mean he writes your favorite song so i
feel like he's approached he's kind of a
weird dude though
yeah but i think he's unique yeah he
really is really unique he has his own
look he's so confident
that's one of the things i love about
him yeah he really do he really does
have that air of confidence he wears
like all white pajamas on the um yeah
but that's what's great about it
so you know um you mentioned building a
fan base on youtube and i was looking
through the comments of a youtube video
and
someone had commented
this is a comment that someone had done
they said omg i would do anything to
meet you because i just want to give you
the world's biggest hug i got goosebumps
and i started to cry would you ever
really want to meet that person does
that seem kind of like oh yeah i don't
think that's awkward at all that those
comments always make my day oh awesome i
appreciate that i think there are i
think fans are so important
like my goal in life is to also meet all
my fans okay that's really cool and you
know this person said that you know
your song made them get emotional and
kind of cry i mean how does that feel to
make that big of an impact on someone's
on someone's emotions that means so much
to me because like one of the reasons
why i do music is to inspire others and
you know get the message across and that
helps me know that i'm doing what i you
know wanted yeah absolutely
is there a
favorite part that you have about
performing on youtube
um yeah what i love about it is i know
that i have the freedom to you know
sing whatever i want there's no one
telling me saying no you can't do this
can't do that you know what i mean it's
just a way where i can express myself
and show others right absolutely and do
you maybe have a least favorite part
about performing on youtube
i would say the least is um
when i get a comment from a fan asking
me to do a cover and basically i don't
want to disappoint them but if like
let's say i'm not loving the song and i
don't usually do covers you know it's
hard saying no to them you know what i
mean so that would be the worst part
absolutely yeah that's definitely
reasonable and you know any other um you
know uh young people your age who want
to start performing on youtube whether
it's singing or doing comedy or dancing
or anything like that what kind of
advice would you give them to kind of
break into the industry of youtube
i the advice i would give them is to
never stop believing work as hard as
they can
there's never heart you can't work hard
enough you cannot you're always gonna
try
and
don't change if someone tells you to
yeah absolutely very cool and then can
you talk about any cool stuff you have
coming up you know um yeah we have a
couple
we have a couple singles we're working
on it's really exciting
so yeah we're thinking of you know
releasing a couple singles so there's a
lot going on i've been recording in the
studio
very cool very cool well thanks so much
for talking to me i really appreciate it
that was so fun yeah awesome awesome
thanks for watching our interview with
heather russell and for more heather
russell you can check her out on her
youtube channel heather russell
officials
to know